MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Grant.
I'm developing a Cloud
Function and I'm having issues
troubleshooting it.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh, have you
tried debugging your function
locally?
MARTIN OMANDER:
Oh no, I haven't.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Let's
pair program together.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So Martin, what's the issue?
Don't you write
perfect code that works
the first time you run it?
MARTIN OMANDER: I wish.
Let me give you some background.
I'm building a Cloud Function
to share all the cute animal
photos you sent me.
Testing the function is
getting fairly complicated.
And I keep getting an error,
trying to fix it, deploy,
wait a minute, test again.
It's taking a lot of time.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Yeah, that does
sound time-consuming and risky,
especially if you're
testing in production.
So let's go and I'll
check out your code
and your function
locally on my machine.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds great.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: So here,
I've checked out your code.
You're a pretty
good coder, but--
sorry.
Focus.
Focus, Grant.
Let me go and show
you how you can go
and run your function locally.
So in this case, we
got a Node function.
To run our function
locally, I'll
first install the Google
Cloud Functions Framework
with npm i @google
cloud/functions framework.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
I'm a pretty good coder, huh?
All right.
So this is Node.
But what about languages
other than Node?
My coworker, for
example, uses Java.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh,
great question, Martin.
So this library-- the
Functions Framework--
is available in all
Cloud Function runtimes.
So the process is pretty similar
between Python, Go, Java, Ruby,
PHP, and .NET.
In fact, there's a link in the
description of this video down
below with documentation
with detailed instructions
for those languages.
So next, we can go and just
use the Functions Framework
for that language
as a library, so you
can run your function locally.
Let's add a start script so
we can simply run npm start.
This will start our localhost
server serving our function.
MARTIN OMANDER: Neat.
So we can just curl
this localhost URL
and test the function locally?
Hm.
Mhm.
Oh, it looks like we're
getting the same error.
Darn.
GRANT TIMMERMAN:
No, Martin, so this
is the error we want to see.
It's actually the
same error that we're
seeing in production.
But now we can go
and test locally.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see.
All right.
So how do we debug this locally?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Well, you can
go use console.log statements,
which I sometimes do.
Don't tell my manager.
But this can be a little
bit cumbersome, especially
with a larger application.
So let's setup
the Node debugger.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That sounds good.
Are you saying that I can
use the normal Node debugger?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Yes.
So Node comes with a
debugger out of the box.
We can simply
attach this debugger
to our Node process
running our function.
So in VS Code, let's
use the Attach command.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, nice.
OK.
All right.
So oh, I see the status bar
change from blue to orange.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Yes.
So that indicates that
we've successfully
attached our debugger.
Now let's add a breakpoint in
the beginning of our function.
[VOCALIZING]
MARTIN OMANDER: Good, good.
All right.
And now let's run our
function, see if we
can catch this pesky error.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: All right.
I'll go and curl
our localhost URL.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
I see the editor has paused
execution on the breakpoint?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Yeah.
In fact, if we go and
hover over some variables,
we can see the current values.
So let's go.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see.
Oh, look at that.
Oh, it looks like
I used req.params
where it should be req.query.
Would you fix that, Grant?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh, yeah.
Sure.
It's a silly typo?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: And it
looks like there's a few more
errors here.
I'll edit them.
And I'm just done.
So now that we've
edited our code,
we need to restart the
function for it to take effect.
One second.
Let me go and just
cancel the process,
restart it, and try again.
And boom.
MARTIN OMANDER: This is great.
But Grant, the function
accesses the Firestore Database
in the cloud.
How come that worked
when you ran the function
on your local machine?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Oh,
great question, Martin.
So the client library
used in the function
picks up the local
credentials from gcloud.
In fact, I ran a special command
to get these credentials.
These are called application
default credentials.
These default credentials are
the exact same credentials
that you see with
Cloud Functions that's
used in production.
So to get this,
I ran the command
gcloud auth application-default
login before I set this.
So remember that Firestore isn't
running on our local machine.
It's the function is using the
client library and our auth
to call the Firestore
Database on our cloud project.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see.
So Grant, how about
we close the loop
and deploy the code to
Google Cloud Functions?
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Sounds great.
Let me run the deploy script
here, gcloud functions deploy.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
it looks like it deployed.
And now let's curl the function.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Great.
Curling the function
with our URL.
And it looks like it works.
It looks like we don't see the
error of an undefined variable
anymore.
I'll click the photo link and
see if it actually worked.
Aw, look at that
cute puppy, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER:
[LAUGHS] Yes, so furry.
I'm happy the function works.
GRANT TIMMERMAN: Well, it
sounds like we definitely
deserve a coffee break.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes,
we've earned it.
Great.
Thank you, everyone,
for watching.
If you have any questions
for me or Grant,
please add them in
the comments below.
Also, please let
us know if you have
another serverless
topic that you'd like
to see us cover in a video.
Bye for now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]